[Music]
you just recently became a dad
yes very recently yeah thank you
he's fighting so yeah five months old
now yeah he's five months old today and
it's um yeah it's going pretty awesome I
mean I'm having a really good time with
it I think I think I'm an okay dad I
mean hard to tell five months in he's
like he's teething right now he's not
really sleeping he's having a hard time
going between the bottle and the breast
but it's it's all gonna although I try
yeah here's the thing that you you will
I tried her bright ride the breast milk
recently wait a minute what am i you
tried the breast milk well I tried it
because I actually tried to get it from
her boob and she wasn't she she kind of
shot me down I don't know why does she
know you were coming you're white you
talk about your wife you you went up to
the breast to try and get milk for yes
right had her boobs out I think she was
about the pump and I wanted that you
want to you know pump two to bottle
there's just a bear I'm out I don't know
yeah something you're just dry enough
and well I just wanted to try I just
wanted to know what it was like and I
kind of went in there and she just was
really like what are you doing and I was
like well I just want to I feel like I
could its I have a right to it as well
don't I don't think you know so I just
tried it when it was in the bottle okay
you tried it yeah I like I never had any
oh you weren't curious about it no not
at all it's listen not even a little bit
I just wanted to see what the fuss is
about my kid loves it so I use it now
all the babies are talking about it go
go go go go go my kid goes bananas for
this little in your coffee but I
wouldn't just take a straight shot of
that made the ice cream or something you
know that's a great idea actually it is
a good idea and we're gonna market it
that's a good idea I am NOT the only guy
to try their wife's breast milk I am
definitely not were you attempted at all
and I took one sip and I found it
repulsive okay it wasn't like a breast
milk or I swung by yeah I said and you
went back it was a drive yeah yeah see I
mean people do it it's not like I have
like a cup of it right you know no no
mmm breast milk it was weird too because
like I also too milk mustache I I
guest-hosted I filled in for Regis a
number of years ago and the thing that
was going on in New York was some
restaurant was making human breast milk
cheese and they surprised us with
samples of it and you know wanting to be
liked of course I tried it and it yet
again and it should be the most natural
thing because it's it's you know our
animal is making it
it was the grossest thing ever it was
the grossest thing ever on region did
Regis have so I was Regis that day I was
filling in for me
there's so many things wrong with this
is the north I know I read just wasn't
there yeah we just called in sick hey
I'm doing what
I'm not eating breast milk cheese
you